tonight for the tampa bay devil raise
it's going to be ryan yarbrough making
his 16th start of the season 21st
overall appearance and looking to pick
up right where he left off his last
outing came against the indians in
cleveland he went seven strong innings
gave up just one earned run striking out
six in a no decision did that all on 92
pitches so very efficient and that's
what he'll be looking to do here tonight
against a very deep and talented boston
lineup
jd 290 20 home runs driven in 65 so red
sox have had
some very very good games against them
he's going to break his bat and drop a
base hit in here comes raffy he's around
to score
jd martinez will pick up his 66th rbi
and the red sox strike first tonight one
to nothing oh he went down there and got
a change up good pitch by yarborough
but better hitting by jd
now xander 308 15 homers he's not good
53
martinez aboard
sucks this one that one is driven out to
right center field that's a shot and
that ball is out of here that's gone
xander bogarts with number 16.
now you're a little less concerned yeah
i haven't seen a little pop in a little
while and asking you shall receive by
bogart he put a charge into that didn't
he he did we haven't seen a shot like
that for a long time from him that is a
great sign for the red sox so run
support immediately for nathan vivaldi
he's nine and five and a 349 era roy has
been so consistent all year long
last two starts against the yankees were
as good as ever
that's a liner into right center field
that's going to be in there wow around
first he's going to dig for second and
the throttle is not in time got that
right hand on the bag and hug on
so he has himself a double
little battle out there with bogarts
when he went in head first
with that hand on the back
[Music]
the fastball had some elevation but
brandon loud quicker to the spot
g-man hitting
at 258 seven homer's 29 knocked in
the right that baby's gonna get out of
here gone
it's his eighth home run
and it's suddenly three to two raves get
two of those right back yeah how about
the answer
i'll tell you the ray's coming ready to
play that offense has been on fire the
last couple of games as we documented in
the open
and they've been getting it done with
the long ball this is now home run
number eight in the last two plus
innings
[Applause]
well he was
possession perfectly
but could not come up with that
and laos gonna reach on the error
and it's lined into right
another big set for choice
loud's on his way to third the throw
there is not in time and now talk
quickly back across to first and troy
who had made a big turn there gets back
in safely
so it's first and third for the ball
flying all over the place
the ground ball right side
and it's booted again throw to first
it's not gonna be in time
the raves get the run to tie this game
and haraju is having a difficult time
out there at second base francisco mejia
shot back into right center that's got
good carry and will go
home run off the bat
and the raise grant the lead
francisco maher control of that one his
fifth home run of the year
and the raise
we started this game down three nothing
now lead five to three continuing to
battle and not giving away at bats and
you finally get a mistake there thigh
high middle of the plate
this guy is perfect for bobby d stay
back and hit one out of here
2-2 on the way
turns on that he's smoking this one is
way out of here
bobby dumbach hits the daylights out of
it ties the ball game 5-5
boy i should have called that thing i i
just knew it i said you throw himself
off he's waiting 2-2 pitch
five-ball short center here comes
hurry got it sliding grab by keermeyer
in shallow center field
he had to come in fear to his left and
then make the sliding catch for out
number two
3-2 from 3-0 on the fastball
now the 3-2
and he got it fastball up a bit and he
strikes him out
kittredge comes back
from being three-and-oh
and using the fastball strikes out
basket entries one pitch away from
getting out of a very difficult spot
the o2
keegan struck him out fastball he went
95 away
what a job by andrew kittredge he
strikes out the side
leaves the vases loaded
wanders grounded a short line to shore
3-2 runner goes and the pit
ball up the right side beyond the
bullpen
wendell's going to be waved around third
renfro gets to the ball
now headed to third franco and he is
safely in there ray's lead
6-5 on a three-base hit by wander bronco
bronco takes the 3-2 pitch just fair
and the rays grab the lead again i'll
tell you he worked a very tough and bad
at wander franco and he is some kind of
fired up 3-2
two outs bases loaded runners will be
off
and the pitch
he gets a swing and a miss
he strikes him out
boston will leave the bases loaded
nitto shoots it into right that's going
to be in there
one hop into the wall extra bases
renfro got a good carom but no chance
and in its second a double for austin
meadows attacking on some runs the
breaking ball by adavino great job by
austin meadows to stay back on it
everything on time and he fires on it
gets it to the wall and right
and a liner right there's a base hit
that will score phillips he's headed to
the plate and the rays pick up another
run it's 7-5
franco who gave the raise the lead in
the sixth tacks on around here in the
eighth
and a base head up the middle in the
center
here comes rosarina bronco's going to
score
mahayana drives in two more to give the
rays some insurance and now it's 9-5
third and fourth runs bannon end of the
ball game for francisco mejia trying to
go back into first for the first time
since june the 26th
and the ground ball to short should do
it
broncos throw to first to the ranger in
first place